many of the classic films produced in
the 1980s are now available to stream
whether you're in the mood for a science
fiction classic or a raunchy comedy
vehicle from an iconic John Hughes movie
to the debut of a spike Lee joint and
everything in between here are the best
80s movies to watch on Netflix if you're
a Spike Lee fan that means she's got a
have it's an essential watch however the
film's impact goes far beyond Lee's own
career yes she's got to have it is Lee's
debut feature and the film that helped
him go on to make things like do the
right thing and jungle fever in the
years that followed but it's also a
milestone for other reasons Lee worked
with a low-budget shot in black and
white and remained as creative as
possible with few resources at a time
when independent film was not yet the
booming subculture it would later become
plus Lee's film help blazed a trail for
both his own filmography and for other
black filmmakers to come perhaps no
other filmmaker is more associated with
the overall aesthetic of 80s movies than
John Hughes the writer director who rose
to prominence over the course of the
decade and redefined teen comedy genre
forever though Hughes filmography is
actually rather diverse when taken as a
whole the mid to late 1980s were the
time in which he very successfully honed
in on a single target the disaffected
American teenager sadly most of Hughes
team comedy classics are not available
on Netflix at the moment but Ferris
Bueller's Day Off is there for you to
rewatch to your heart's content the film
follows the title character played with
undeniable charisma by Matthew Broderick
as he decides to take a sick day from
school and turn it into the best
vacation possible all while his
suspicious principal is hot on his trail
it's not the most realistic of Hugh's
films but it is one of the most
delightful in the 1970s both Steven
Spielberg and George Lucas had breakout
hits that essentially invented the
modern-day blockbuster Spielberg with
his stylish shark Scarefest jaws and
Lucas with his mythic space opera star
wars in the 1980s the two friends joined
forces to further reinvent mainstream
commercial cinema with the series of
films inspired by matinee adventure
serials starring a dashing hero with a
bullwhip and a fedora
[Music]
the original indiana jones trilogy that
spans the 1980s still holds up is one of
the best action franchises in film
history starring the iconic harrison for
the first film Raiders of the Lost Ark
is basically a perfect adventure movie
Indiana Jones and the Temple of Doom
can't quite live up to its predecessor
but still has its defenders and Indiana
Jones in the Last Crusade brings us the
can't miss super team of Ford and Sean
Connery as Indies father even if you've
seen them dozens of times the Indiana
Jones films are the kind of experience
that don't get dull with time the early
1980s was a very fruitful time for
horror cinema and produced several
highly influential films that launched
careers and paved the way for the genres
prevalence through the decade unknown
filmmaker Sam Raimi released a movie he
made out in the woods with his friends
and launched a new wave of splattering
supernatural horror The Evil Dead not
only launched a franchise but it also
launched the careers of Raimi and star
Bruce Campbell it's a film that courted
both controversy and a rabid fan
following thanks to its extreme content
and wicked sense of humor and launched a
wave of low-budget gory often darkly
comic films in its wake
Ramey's fingerprints are still all over
the horror landscape today and this is
the film that launched it all people who
have never seen succeed might simply
dismiss it as that comedy were Dustin
Hoffman Krauss dresses well that is
indeed the linchpin of the film's plot
Sydney Pollack's movie about a desperate
actor who decides to be a woman to land
a job is much more than a one-note joke
the film has gone down in history as not
just one of the best films of the 1980s
but as one of the best American films of
all time you are the first woman
character who is her own person who can
assert her own personality without
robbing someone of theirs you're a
breakthrough lady for us Dustin Hoffman
is of course relentlessly entertaining
as he dons drag but the film also has
something more to say about the sexist
commercial istic Drive of the 1980s
which still holds true today it's a film
about changing attitudes changing times
and changing people all wrapped up in a
delightful comedic shell it's as
rewarding on the first watch as it is
every time you return cold war films
became big bold metaphors in the 1980s
and they were often just an excuse to
cheer for the American Way of life and
read
is a great example of that the film
tells the story of a group of teenagers
trying to not just survive but triumph
in the midst of World War three and a
communist invasion of America the actual
war is happening largely in the
background which means the audience
mostly just gets to savor the exploits
of the rule verrines led by stars like
Charlie Sheen Patrick Swayze and Lea
Thompson if you're looking for a film
that stands as a very clear testament to
the American movie landscape at the time
Red Dawn is a good place to start the
1980s were a particularly robust period
when it came to various forms of raunchy
comedy and there were a few filmmakers
who were going to live up to that
standard with rapid-fire jokes countless
sight gags and actors who were willing
to go the extra mile for comedy gold why
should I tell you
still no think I should tell you just
bought me a twenty one of the best
examples of this comes in the form of
The Naked Gun the first film in the
trilogy created by Jim Abrams Pat proft
and the Zucker Brothers based on their
short-lived TV series police squad the
film is a delightful send-up of serious
cop dramas and follows detective Frank
Drebin played by the incomparable Leslie
Nielsen as he tries to protect the Queen
of England during her visit to the
United States the film is just
wall-to-wall gags delivered by the
entire cast and it's a reminder that
there was no other comedy star quite
like Leslie Nielsen chick camara signal
now put into traffic raunchy comedies
were all the rage in the 1980s but there
was a particular focus on films about a
ragtag band of misfits who get the
better of their authority figures
through open defiance and behind the
back silliness it's how we got films
like stripes and Revenge of the Nerds
and it's also how he got the police
academy series the first film in the
franchise follows a group of wannabe
cops as they head into the Academy and
face off against Stern often cruel
supervisors as the film goes on they
prove that they can be great cops while
also being Complete Idiot's the film is
packed with memorable performances but
if you're watching it now the best part
might turn out to be Michael Winslow's
uncanny sound effects Purple Rain still
stands as an entertaining film in part
because it really does feel like nothing
more than an excuse to tout the stylish
sensual appeal that Prince had
mid-1980s the purple ones film works on
a purely entertaining level but then it
goes deeper when you really sit down and
watch Purple Rain what you find is a
surprisingly emotionally satisfying
story about trauma recovery and breaking
cycles of abuse through creativity
prince is both vulnerable and commanding
in the lead role Morris Day is an
absolute scene stealer and by the time
of that final number you'll be standing
and cheering along with the ANU v--
audience what made the 1980s slasher
boom great for those who were fans of
the sub-genre was the moments when
filmmakers decided to go beyond the
roots of the boom and instead just when
is off the rails as possible you can see
the fruits of that labor in films like a
Nightmare on Elm Street chopping mall
and of course child's play
in some ways child's play is the
ultimate 1980s slasher movie story and
that it is basically a metaphor for
consumerism coming for us in the form of
an evil product that wicked little
metaphor is hanging over everything but
it's also just a full-tilt dark comedy
horror show full of creative kills and
no matter how used to seeing him you
might be Chucky still has the power to
scare you over the course of child's
plays 90 minutes when we look back on a
pop culture decade as wild as the 1980s
it's intriguing to look at the films
that audiences and critics didn't
immediately latch onto that eventually
became cult classics today Blade Runner
ranks as one of the greatest science
fiction films ever made
lauded as a groundbreaking piece of dark
futuristic storytelling and one of the
finest works in director Ridley Scott's
career when it first debuted though
Scott's film earned a lackluster
reception despite its dazzling visuals
amazing cast an unforgettable soundtrack
now we can look back on Blade Runner
with the benefit of hindsight in the
form of Scott's final cut of the film
which removes things like the dull
voiceover from the original release and
adds back in key scenes that layer
deeper meaning into the film Martin
Scorsese has produced at least one
masterpiece every decade since the 1970s
delivering a diverse and exciting
filmography that's so much more than the
gangster films for which he is most
famous though later classics of the
decade would follow Scorsese started the
1980s with one of his most dynamic
masterpieces Raging Bull the
black-and-white film is the story of
Jake the Bronx bull LaMotta
a legendary boxer to
to be the best and toughest fighter of
his generation led by Robert DeNiro who
earned his second Oscar for the role the
film follows LaMotta through personal
and professional triumphs and torments
as he tries to balance his violent
career with his often tumultuous family
life
brilliant supporting performances from
Joe Pesci and Kathy Moriarty complete
the picture and Raging Bull remains an
essential part of the Scorsese Canon
movie subgenres are usually not invented
overnight you can't necessarily point to
one film that's the first slasher movie
or the first romantic comedy that's why
we can't really call a lethal weapon the
first buddy cop movie particularly not
when films like 48 hours came before it
that said the film has emerged as the
definitive buddy cop movie in the years
since its 1987 release it follows the
now classic formula two mismatched cops
learning to work together to save the
day Mel Gibson and Danny Glover have
amazing chemistry and the whole film has
this sense of unhinged energy batard to
replicate Lethal Weapon launched a
franchise with three sequels and a TV
series but none of them can top the
original Raj corner
I'm too old for this sometimes the
stereotypical 80s action movie
experience is exactly what you want it
to be full of corny dialogue and oiled
up men ready to brawl bloodsport is
definitely that kind of movie Jesus for
you Shidoshi jean-claude Van Damme's
breakout film casts him as a US Army
captain who decides to go AWOL so he can
head to Hong Kong and fight in a secret
illegal martial arts tournament against
contenders from around the world along
the way he forges friendships makes
enemies and reveals through copious
flashbacks why the tournament is so
important to him what sport has a lot
going for it even if you're an 80s
action fan plus it features Van Damme
doing this famous splits over and over
again to great effect check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]